hey nascar drops the green flag at the
las vegas motor speedway this weekend as
fans roll into the stands
with covert bringing out the caution
flag there are some do's and don'ts and
john treach here to make sure
all those fans have a checkered flag
weekend
nascar fans love the monster x the messy
burnouts
and the dramatic exhaust but this year
the pins oil 400 is going to start on
green
and stay clean they may trade paint on
the trap
they won't be trading germs in the
grandstand because we want race fans to
know when they come to las vegas motor
speedway
safety is the top priority more
assertive than a kyle busch two-tire pit
stop
is the sanitation crew professional
preventative
and protocol driven this grandstand that
i'm standing in spans three quarters of
a mile
and we could put in two or three times
the number that we're allowed
still keep people physically distanced
and still keep everyone safe
the speedway's world famous fan
experience will have to pump the brakes
in 2021
there won't be rvs pit passes or neon
garage
access so it's going to be different and
strange because we don't have those
experiences to
interact with the drivers and all those
things that they let you do
but at least being a big nascar fan
we're back seeing racing live
in september there were no fans now
there will be 12 thousand five hundred
if you love racing it's a hard left turn
toward heaven
it's the sound of the engines the smells
hearing the pit stops and the speed at
which they operate
and the speed of the actual cars that it
just it doesn't convey that on tv
the nascar cup series in las vegas a
tradition since
1998 and this weekend it's full speed
ahead
reporting from las vegas motor speedway
john treach 8 sports now